The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
OK.
Let's get started.
One announcement
is a reminder.
There is a paper due on April
4, and Michaela will be
sending out a formal assignment
about that within a
day or two.
So you can get started on
that whenever you like.
And we can talk about it more
next week after the
assignment comes out.
But for the most part, what it's
going to look like is an
assignment to do a little more
digging and some research
into, basically, people, place,
or thing in the part of
the history of MIT that
we've covered so far.
So take a particular person--
maybe one of the signers of
the charter or one of the
early professors or an
early student here--
a place, one particular building
from the period up to
1915 or so.
And we say thing, but I think
that could be an instrument or
a laboratory that is of interest
and do a little
profile of that about what was
it used for, what were people
studying in the laboratory,
and how were
people being taught--
and basically, to focus on the
first 65 years or so--
50 years or so.
The 50th anniversary of MIT is
1911, so something from that
early period that
interests you.
There's a lot of material, both
online, but also in the
MIT archives, in
the libraries.
Actually, a really good source
is just, of the books that
we've been assigning pieces of,
you can just look further
into those books.
And Michaela will help you with
that and actually have
maybe a special session on some
of the research methods
and what to expect for that.
So that's coming along.
And next week, we'll have Ros
Williams in, who will talk
about a combination of things.
She's a historian of
technology as well.
She's written about the
history of MIT and the
chemical engineering department,
which happens to
have been founded by her
grandfather, who had a lot of
interesting personalities on
campus and things he was
involved in.
Today, we are lucky to have Ross
Bassett with us who is a
colleague of ours from NC State,
has written a very good
book on the history of CMOS
technology and the equation of
the semiconductor integrated
circuits.
And now, he's working on this
book part of the assignment,
which was the reading today on
the Indian students at MIT.
And he's going to talk to us
a little bit about that.
And over lunch, it was just
becoming clear how many of the
issues that were raised both
in the readings and also in
the response papers for today
are, as some of you pointed
out, relevant for issues
on campus.
We happened to be sitting two
tables down from Tom Mangnati,
who's the former dean of
engineering here and the
president of the new university
in Singapore that
MIT has founded based
on the principle of
organizing around design.
And so as many of you will have
heard from a variety of
things, MIT's relationships with
the rest of the world--
its profile abroad is very much
a topic of conversation
at MIT these days.
How many of you work in a lab
that has some connection with
Singapore or some other
international research group?
So a few of you do.
And how many of you were born
and raised in the US versus--
so yeah.
Undergraduates--
very much more American-based.
The undergraduate population
is capped at about 8%
international students, whereas
the graduate student
population is probably--
I don't know the
exact number--
50% or 60% international
students.
But even of the US-born,
US-raised undergraduate
students, many come from
families, first generation
immigrants or whatnot.
We've talked about that
a little bit before.
So Ros will talk to us a
little bit about Indian
students at MIT.
It's a very interesting case.
There's a lot of interesting
reasons to be interested in
India and MIT's relationships
there-- but also not
necessarily typical, but
representative of MIT's
relationships with Japan, China,
Iran, Middle East--
lots of different places
around the world.
All of them are a little bit
special, but they're certainly
part of a longer story here.
So he's going to talk for a
little bit, put the article in
the context of a larger project
that he's working on,
and then we can pick up
the discussion there.
And I think that'll naturally
segue into also this
particular period that
we've come into--
turn of the century up through
the beginning of World War II,
the technology plan,
relationships with industry.
Again, so many of the issues
from the reading that were on
the table in 1915, 1930 are
still issues that are on the
table today in some
form or another.
ROSS BASSETT: Thanks, David
and Roe and Michaela.
I think it's a good strategy to
start out by sucking up to
your audience.
So let me do that.
I've got my Ph.D.
from Princeton.
And there was a Professor,
Michael
Borden, who went to Harvard.
And when he went to Harvard, he
had a roommate at Harvard
who was of Indian ancestry.
And Michael reported that his
roommate told him how all his
family back in India were all so
proud that they had someone
in their family who went
to a school near MIT.
And it gives you an idea, I
think, of what the sense of
MIT is in India.
And so I've been to India
a lot and I've
seen that first hand.
So a couple things, just to put
this in context and why
I'm interested in this.
I've been interested in India
for a long time, and I'm also
interested in globalization,
of course.
That's a big buzz
word these days.
But one of the ways I think
about history and how we can
find interesting history topics
is sort of a thought
experiment.
Imagine, say, what would
surprise someone coming to the
year 2011 from, say,
100 years ago?
Say, President Maclaurin--
what would surprise them
about the world
today if they saw it?
And so I think about that,
I guess, especially
with regard to India.
And let me just say some of the
things that I think would
be pretty surprising.
I guess anything involving
Indians in the United States
would be surprising, because
they were actually laws
limiting Indians from staying
permanently in America.
It was very questionable whether
an Indian, someone
from India, could even become a
citizen of the United States
until 1920.
Until 1965, the United States
had laws which basically said,
we really don't want Indians
in the United States.
There was an annual quota
of 100 people.
But let me tell you some things
about the world of 2011
that is sort of surprising
in that regard.
Silicon Valley--
my apologies--
but the most dynamic
technological area in the world.
It's commonly said that Silicon
Valley runs on ICs.
And that doesn't mean
integrated circuits.
It means Indians and Chinese.
People understand that Indian
and Chinese entrepreneurs are
some of the key figures who
really start businesses
successfully, help move
the technology along.
I think of that school
down the road a bit.
They just appointed a new dean
of their business school.
His name is Nitin Nohria, an
Indian who came to Harvard.
MIT itself, the former dean of
engineering, Subra Suresh,
also from India.
Now he's the head of the
National Science Foundation,
one of the leading funders of
science and technological
research in the United States,
setting the agenda for
scientific research.
I think of--
do you know the building that's
right across Vassar
Street from the Stata Center,
the Institute for Brain
Research, that the
train tracks go
through the middle of?
That was designed by Charles
Correa, an Indian, someone
who's the leading Indian
architect.
And so he lives in India.
This was his first commission
ever in the United States for
an American client.
And so the point of this is
that Indians play a very
prominent role in technology
in the United States today,
which I think would have been
very, very surprising to
anyone 100 years ago.
And then if we look at India
itself, there are a number of
things, I think, that are
surprising as well.
We're used to seeing everything
that we buy from
Walmart or Target or whatever
having a "made in
China" stamp on it.
We can't really judge the
provenance of software code or
something like that.
But if could, we'd probably be
surprised at how much software
would have the tag
"coded in India."
And I was in India in October
and visited a place where they
made transmission components for
Fords and GMs in a place
in Pune, India.
Another big Indian company is
set to, I think this year,
begin selling its model SUV
in the United States.
So India is playing a remarkable
technological role
in United States.
We might have considered
that inconceivable 100
years ago or so.
So that's what I've been
interested in looking at.
And the way I decided to do this
was I was trying to look
for some way to understand the
relationship between the
United States and India.
And the way I finally decided to
do it was that I found that
MIT has a series of commencement
programs that
they publish with every
commencement
that lists every graduate.
And they've listed the hometown
of every graduate.
And so they have these
available for
the whole 20th century.
So what I did is I
made a database.
I went through these and pulled
out every single Indian
who graduated from MIT
in the 20th century.
So I have this database,
and I kind of think
of this as a filter.
India is a country with a
population now of a billion
people or so.
We can't look at all
1 billion people.
So what I'm looking at is those
Indians throughout the
century who came to MIT.
And so again, we can't look at
every student at MIT from the
20th century.
But we can look at--
this is a rather small group.
It's about 1,500 people or so.
And so let's look at these
students and say, how did they
end up getting from India,
7,000 miles away, to MIT?
How did that happen?
And then what happened
to them afterwards?
What did they do?
Did they make any difference
in India?
What were their careers like?
And so that's what
I've been doing.
And so in the last five years
or so, I've been running
around India trying to track
down Indian graduates of MIT,
their family and so on,
just to find out some
things about them.
And so a couple of general
themes that
come up from this--
one is the idea of a
technological nationalism, I
would say, and then also the
development of the information
technology industry in India
and globalization.
Then also--
in Star Trek, they have this
tractor beam that sometimes
will pull things into
the spaceship.
You could say MIT has been
a tractor beam for global
talent, that it's pulled
international talent into the
United States, and very often
it's stayed in the United
States after it's
gotten there.
So these are some of the things
that I'm touching on in
what I'm doing.
And so one of the things that
you do see is students who
went to MIT in the early
20th century--
very often, going to MIT,
you could say, was
a nationalist act.
India was a British colony, and
most people, in some ways,
the intuitive thing to do would
be to make ties with the
British, British society,
with Britain.
So those who went to MIT were
in some ways doing something
that didn't make a lot of sense
in some ways, having
ties with the British.
And so that that's a big theme
that I've discovered.
And one of the other aspects of
this that has been kind of
intriguing--
what do you think of when you
think of Mahatma Gandhi?
What sorts of things
come to your mind?
What sort of images?
What kind of things
do you think of?
AUDIENCE: Small, peaceful man.
ROSS BASSETT: Small,
peaceful man.
Anything else you think
of about Gandhi?
AUDIENCE: He was fairly
well to do and then
he gave it all up.
ROSS BASSETT: He was
a very wealthy
lawyer, gave it all up.
AUDIENCE: Spiritualism.
ROSS BASSETT: Pardon?
ROSS BASSETT: Spiritualism.
Anyone else?
So we have those images
of Gandhi.
One of the intriguing things
about this research--
when I look at the Indians who
went to MIT in the 1920s and
1930s and try to look at the
networks of people they're
involved in, where they come
from, one of the things that I
find is, if I try to identify
where is the
heart of these people--
what sort of, again,
networks are they
involved in and so on--
if you look at a large number
of them, you get connected
back to Gandhi, that a large
percentage of Indians were
from the part of India where
Gandhi was from.
A large number of them
actually had
connections with Gandhi.
One young man who grew up in
Gandhi's ashram went to MIT.
And so this has been the
intriguing thing.
And it's suggested some
things to me.
I've gone back and looked
at Gandhi's papers.
And Gandhi has often been, I'd
say, captured by political
historians--
most people who are interested
in him are people interested
in political history, Gandhi's
spiritualism, his philosophy,
his philosophy of nonviolence,
and things like that.
But Gandhi was very interested
in technology himself.
Maybe the most common image
of him being interested in
technology, of course,
is handspinning.
And it's easy to see
that as very
regressive, you might say--
very archaic.
But he was really very
interested in efficiency, as
he was interested in spinning.
If you were a contemporary of
Gandhi's and you told him you
spun, he would ask you what
your production rate was.
And he was very concerned about
increasing production.
His magazine had statistics
all the time about what
people's spinning production
was and so on.
And so it seems like Gandhi had
this-- and I think this
term has come across before in
some of your other readings.
He was almost tailoristic is
taken some of his ways, that
he was very concerned
about efficiency.
He once wrote a piece
in his newspaper--
20 rules that anyone who was
going to meet him at the
railroad station
should follow.
And he was kind of upset in this
that he said, a lot of
people who met him at the train
station would block his
path of going out of
the train station.
He said, normally, it should
take me five minutes, but now
all these people are there.
It's taking me 30 minutes.
I'm wasting all this time.
And so he was very frustrated
with that.
And so he was very interested
in efficiency.
And it seems one young man who
grew up in Gandhi's ashram
basically said later on, I
became an engineer at the
hands of Gandhi.
Gandhi made me an engineer.
And again, it seems, in some
ways, fairly counterintuitive.
But that was what he said he saw
and that was how he became
an engineer.
And so many of these people
went to MIT as this act of
technological nationalism.
They saw that if India was going
to be an independent
country, they needed to have
a technological base.
They needed to have
technological capabilities so
they wouldn't be relying on
British people, Americans,
that they could develop their
own technological
infrastructure.
And so that seems to have been a
very big theme among Indians
who went to MIT in the early
part of the 20th century.
I want to flip through
some of these--
PROFESSOR: We can if you want.
ROSS BASSETT: Sure,
that'd be great.
This is Alfred Marshall,
the British economist.
One man had studied
at Cambridge--
an Indian man-- and Alfred
Marshall told him, as I
mentioned in the paper, that he
thought Indians should not
be going to Cambridge,
but instead
should be going to MIT.
This is [INAUDIBLE]
who I mentioned in
the article.
He started a chemical works
in Western India.
This is a drawing of the
chemical works in the small
town of [INAUDIBLE]
in Kathiawar.
You can just flip
through that.
This is a picture of Mahatma
Gandhi and [INAUDIBLE]
So here's Mahatma Gandhi and
this is [INAUDIBLE].
So this is in 1950.
Gandhi had just come back
from South Africa.
And [INAUDIBLE]
was this person who was very
interested in sending people
to MIT, sent a number of his
family members to MIT.
And this is a young man I
mentioned in the paper.
Again, Gandhi was present
at his wedding.
And then, the next year,
he went to MIT.
And he was in the cooperative
program in electrical
engineering and he got a
Bachelor's and Master's degree
in electrical engineering and
then returned to India.
And in India, he had this double
life, you could say.
I would say he was probably
one of the best trained
engineers in electrical
engineering in India, having
this Master's degree in
electrical engineering.
But if you were to look at his
career from a purely technical
standpoint, he kind of
under-utilized his education.
He was very much involved in
the Nationalist Movement.
He was thrown into jail for his
participation in the Salt
Satyagraha.
He later led a large strike at
one of India's leading steel
plants and was thrown into jail
for 18 months after that.
If you can just hit
the next slide.
Here's a picture of
him at MIT again.
He apparently got training in
the military cadet program.
And again, it was kind
of intriguing to me--
after he was in jail for 18
months, he still maintained
very good relations with his
former MIT professors.
He kept in touch with them,
exchanged letters.
So he didn't see some sort of
dichotomy between his role as
a protester for freedom, as a
Gandhian, and his career as an
engineer at MIT, or as
MIT-trained engineer.
This is the diwan, sort of the
prime minister of a princely
state of India in Bhavnagar
in Western India.
This man was an associate
of Gandhi.
India had these princely states,
and he paid for a
number of Indians
to go to MIT.
And then this is a kind
of intriguing
meeting in the late 1930s.
The diwan, Prabhashankar Pattani
is sitting down there
in the turban.
He came to MIT and he hosted all
the Indian MIT students to
have lunch at the Ritz
Carlton Hotel.
And so here they all are.
One of them was married
to an American woman.
So you see this small collection
of Indian students
there at MIT around 1939.
And then this is a young
man, Bal Kalelkar.
He was the young man who was
raised in Gandhi's ashram.
Here's Gandhi right here.
And then this is Kalelkar
right behind him.
This is a letter that
Kalelkar wrote.
And Gandhi was a
famous editor.
He was an editor
of a newspaper.
And Kalelkar wrote this letter
to GD Birla, who was one of
India's richest businessmen.
You might think of him
as an analog of Bill
Gates at the time.
And Kalelkar wrote GD Birla,
asking him to fund his
education at MIT.
And Gandhi edited the
letter, helped him
make the right approach.
Gandhi was a friend
of this man.
And so he went through and make
corrections and so on.
This is something that I found
in India, and this is the next
part of it.
This is, again, Gandhi's
editing.
He tells Kalelkar, incorporate
these changes and send it off.
But the point is, I would have
thought the natural tendency
of Gandhi would be to not be so
enthusiastic about someone
going to MIT.
And he obviously could have
refused to support him in
seeking this funding.
But Gandhi supported him
to get this funding.
Once, Gandhi had asked his
friend to provide funding,
once he had given him this
letter, it would have been
fairly hard for this
person to resist.
So Gandhi did not see someone
going to MIT as a betrayal of
his movement, as someone who was
turning his back on him.
He was willing to support him.
And this is four Indians at MIT
in about 1940 having fun
in the snow and having
a snowball fight.
There was a fairly rich social
life among the Indians in
1920s and 1930s.
There are records of a number
of pranks that they did on
each other and so on.
After one of them completed
doctoral examination, he
invited a number of friends out
to a restaurant out west
of Cambridge.
And then he and his friend snuck
out and drove back home
and stiffed everyone else and
left them both rideless and
having to pay the bill.
And this caused a number of
repercussions afterwards.
This is a cartoon of Anant
Pandya, who was the first
Indian to get a Ph.D.
from MIT.
And then he became the first
Indian principal of an
engineering college in India.
This was at college near
Calcutta called the Bengal
Engineering College.
And again, it's hard
to imagine what
this would have meant.
I think, generally, the Brits
had to the general idea that
they were superior, that in some
ways, one of the aspects
of colonialism was that the
British, the Europeans were
superior in technology.
And that was in some ways the
basis for colonialism.
Once people like Anant Pandya
came out and were able--
Pandya won this position as a
principal of this college in
an open competition
with Brits--
and Brits then worked under
him, it really made a
statement that technology was
not just something that was
limited to Europeans
and Euro-Americans.
I mention in the paper, again,
that one of the key moments
before independence--
you think about technological
nationalism--
was that, as India stood on
the brink of independence,
Indians began to say,
we need something
like an MIT for India.
And so this was the committee
report that established the
Indian Institutes of Technology,
which were, again,
India's institutes
analogous to MIT.
Two Indian MIT graduates sat on
this committee and helped
establish this committee.
This is, again, a picture
of Anant Pandya.
He had a position as the head of
the major Indian aerospace
company, and again, was the
first Indian director of that.
And then he died, tragically,
in a car accident.
And then he was at memorialized
in a magazine
that was talking about
his career and his
connection with MIT.
And this seems to have had a
big effect on a number of
people, just making them want
to become engineers and also
making them want to go to MIT.
Now, I just want to say a little
bit about India and IT.
One of the interesting things,
I think, about globalization
is I'd say globalization is,
in some ways, based on
similarities and differences
between countries, that if you
think of the boundary
conditions--
if every country was exactly the
same, there'd be no point
in globalization, because
India would be just like
United States.
There would be no point in
moving work or doing things
between countries.
But if countries were
diametrically opposed and had
nothing in common, then
they couldn't relate.
They couldn't communicate
technologically.
They couldn't have this
technological work done
between them.
And I guess what I'd say is that
Indian graduates of MIT,
especially in the 1950s and '60s
and 1970s, were the key
people who connected the United
States and India in a
technological way, that they
had this possibility of
joining these two countries
together.
They had knowledge.
They were often from upper class
parts of Indian society,
had a lot of knowledge of India,
and then, by virtue of
their education, the
United the States.
They had a great knowledge of
America and understanding of
American technology.
This is the first Indian
IT company.
It was called Tata Consultancy
Services.
And it was founded by
three MIT graduates.
They were basically in
their early 20s.
Tata is a large Indian business
company that has a
number of different business
enterprises.
And they said, we'd like
you to start a
computer business here.
And they didn't really know
what exactly they
were going to do.
They thought of it like an
Arthur D. Little-- if you know
what that is-- a consulting
firm.
So they started this.
And you can see it.
They started it almost on an
American model, and it didn't
work very well initially.
This is their operation
in Bombay.
Again, they thought of it
almost like as a very
academic-oriented thing.
And it wasn't too much concerned
with profit making
And finally, the Tatas got a
little bit frustrated with it.
And these three guys left.
And they ended up hiring
as the head of
it another MIT graduate.
This is a man by the name of
FC Kohli, who is sometimes
considered one of the key
figures in the development of
the information technology
industry in India.
And what he had was-- he
had studied at MIT.
He had a lot of connections in
the United States by virtue of
his time at MIT.
But also, he understood India
and was able to really develop
a successful business doing
software work in India for
American companies.
And so that stood him in very
good stead and helped him
become very successful.
And one of the things I'd say
about him is that when India
started thinking about computer
technology, a lot of
Indians thought in terms
of, let's try to
make our own computers.
Let's try to make our own
computer business.
Let's try to build all the
hardware ourselves.
And Kohli didn't
think that way.
I think he understood what
American industry was capable
of, and he knew India could
never compete with United
States in building computers--
that it was a very capital
intensive business, that they
would never have the volumes
that America would have.
And so it was a losing
proposition to try to think of
doing something like that.
And he had the idea of, let's
just write software.
Let's not try to do all
the computing work.
Let's do software.
That's something where
we have an advantage.
Our labor costs are much less
than American costs.
We can do that.
And he had connections
in America.
I think people in America were
willing to trust him because
of his connections, because
of his MIT education.
And so he got a lot of business
for this company,
Tata Consultancy Services
from the United States.
This is another early
IT information
technology pioneer in India.
His name is Narendra Patni.
And again, he did a great job
of connecting India and the
United States at a time when
there weren't a lot of
connections.
A lot of people in America
didn't know
that much about India.
I could imagine--
this is in the late
1960s, 1970s--
that if you said I'm from India,
I would like to do
computer business for you, I
think that's a pretty big
stretch for a lot of people--
what they knew about India, what
sort of confidence they
have in Indians.
But again, Patni had
come to MIT.
He had work with Jay Forrester,
who was, as a great
academic entrepreneurian,
involved in a lot of things.
And so he had the contacts that
really enabled India to
get this sort of business.
And I think I have
one final slide.
So you see Bill Gates
on the left there.
And then the person
on the right is
named Narayana Murthy.
And he's the founder of another
big Indian IT company
called Infosys.
And Narayana Murthy never went
to MIT, but he was influenced
by MIT in a lot of ways.
He went to this Indian
Institute of
Technology at Kanpur.
And there, his mentors were
Indians who had gone to MIT.
Then he went to another school--
the Indian Institute
of Management--
where his mentor there was
another man, Indian, who had
gone to MIT.
Then he worked for Narendra
Patni, the person that I had
mentioned before.
In a form to an American would
appreciate, after he had
worked with Narendra Patni for a
while, he got tired and quit
and started his own business.
And this became Infosys.
The point of this is he never
could have done that on his
own, but after he had worked
with all these Indians who had
gone to MIT, who had a lot of
connections to the United
States, he had these connections
himself.
And they really helped him to
develop those connections.
One other point--
in some ways, it's easy to see
this is a great success story,
the development of the
Indian IT industry.
One other point I feel like I
have to mention as well--
the greatest industrial accident
in world history
happened in India at
Bhopal in 1984.
Union Carbide had a plant making
methyl isocyanate.
And there was a leak at this
plant, and it killed--
we're still not exactly
sure how many--
maybe 10,000 people.
The manager of this
plant was also an
Indian graduate of MIT.
And again, the point of this is
in the 1960s and 1970s and
1980s, where the United States
and India were linked together
in technology, generally
speaking, you would often find
an MIT graduate somewhere
there.
And so you see them in both
of these contexts.
And so finally, just one other
thing I want to mention is
MIT, as I said, has become for
50 years or so, a tractor beam
for talent coming to
the United States.
Many Indians, as they go
to school in the Indian
Institutes of Technology, want
to pursue their education.
And for them, they see the best
possible place to go to
continue their education
is MIT.
You see it as a dream
for them.
Many of them, when they come
to the United States, don't
imagine that they're going to
stay in the United States, but
often they end up staying
in United States.
Sometimes their education,
I'd say, unfits
them for work in India.
Sometimes they just get so
caught up and see the
opportunities in
United States.
But that seems to be
a major trend.
Now, there are some questions
if it will continue, that
there are enough opportunities
in India that maybe Indians
wouldn't feel such a strong
need to come to the United
States for graduate school.
So these are some of that
the basic themes.
Most of it will be
on the people who
came from India, though.
It wasn't until 1965 that there
were immigration laws
that really let Indians come
to the United States on any
sort of a fair basis.
So you see Indians who are
Indians Americans or second
generation Indians--
you only see them starting
to come to MIT in any
numbers in the '80s.
And then it is ramped up as more
and more Indians are in
the United States.
So it's sort of a later
part of the story.
The two most prestigious fields
you can go into are
medicine or engineering.
And in India there is, I'd
say, almost an idea-- you
don't think of what
you want to do.
You think of what you can do.
And if you can get into an IIT,
then you should do it,
even if you were thinking you
don't have an interest in
engineering-- that you
should just do it.
But they're very, I guess I
would say, focused on things
that will make you a
remunerative career.
And there is a lot of
skepticism, I would say,
generally, that liberal
arts will make you a
remunerative career.
There are some good liberal arts
schools, but relatively
few people go that route.
Most people feel, in a country
of a billion people, that
competition is just so fierce
for jobs that everyone feels
the need to get into some area
where they're sure that
they'll have a good job.
I spoke to a professor at one
of the Indian Institutes of
Technology whose daughter wanted
to go into economics.
And he was kind of horrified
that she wanted to do this.
And he wanted me to explain to
him what economics was, what
kind of job she would get.
And he was half-convinced
afterwards.
He said, well, OK, maybe I'll
let her do economics, but I'm
never going to let her
do liberal arts.
That's drawing a line that
that's not going to happen.
And there's a very strong
feeling that way, that
engineering--
and even within engineering,
there's a certain hierarchy.
Computer science is at
the highest level.
And so these Indian Institutes
of Technology--
entrance to the schools is
determined by one exam called
the joint entrance exam.
You get a score on it and there
might be 100,000 or it
might be 300,000 people
who take this exam.
Your score on it is a rank.
So you're ranked one
to 300,000, say.
And the person who scores one
can choose their seat major in
any of these Indian Institutes
of Technology.
And then the person who gets the
last seat is forced to go
wherever there's an open
seat in a major.
And so invariably, the number
one student would take
computer science.
That's just what they do.
And then there's a hierarchy
of computer science,
electrical engineering,
chemical engineering,
mechanical engineering--
civil engineering is one of the
lowest of the engineering.
And then there's naval
architecture, which is a bit
lower than that, too.
AUDIENCE: In these institutions,
the Indian
Institutes of Technology,
they're all funded by
development or are they
privately funded?
ROSS BASSETT: So these are
funded by the government< and
the tuition is pretty low.
And it's been kind of a
political issue in India.
One issue is how many seats
should be reserved for people
from what's called
the scheduled
caste or backward caste?
So it would be a bit analogous
to affirmative action, say.
And so this has been
very controversial.
How many seats should be
reserved for them?
And then also people in the
middle class have been
clamoring for access to these.
A lot of people have
been shut out.
There were originally five of
these Indian Institutes of
Technology.
Then there were seven.
And now, recently, they've
doubled that.
Each one has become the mentor
to a new Indian Institute of
Technology.
And they've done this for
political reasons, because
there's such a great demand
and so many people want to
enter into these institutions.
And it's very controversial.
A lot of people associated with
the Indian Institutes of
Technology think they'll never
be able to maintain the same
quality in doubling the
institutions that
they've had so far.
And so there's worry of brand
dilution, if you use a
business term of what that's
going to do to these schools.
More stay in India now, and more
of the leaders, I'd say,
from now have been mostly
educated in India than in the
'50s and '60s and so on.
But the system is still-- at
these IITs, they're very good
undergraduate institutions.
But if you want to do serious
graduate research, there's no
question that they are not at
all competitive with MIT.
There is this hierarchy.
It turns out that at an IIT,
if you go there, the best
students are the undergraduates,
and then the
graduates are usually actually
worse students than the
undergraduates.
They're students who are sort
of percolating up from less
prestigious institutions, and as
they go to graduate school,
they go to these IITs.
But the people from the IITs
who want to go to graduate
school almost invariably go to
the United States to go to
graduate school.
There's a clear understanding
of--
they don't have research
funding that American
institutions have that would
enable them to do the same
kind of research that would be
done in the United States.
The system in both politics--
in politics, I don't think you
would ever go to an IIT,
because it's more about
connections within India.
And it's more about being
a political player.
In business.
the environment is so dynamic, I
don't think you need to have
gone to an IIT There's
many institutions
where you can go to.
The IIT--
you clearly can get into an
American institution.
IITs in some ways, for a
long time, were paths
to the United States--
the paths to American
graduate school.
Now, they're paths to American
graduate schools, but they're
also paths to Google in India or
Microsoft in India or other
multinational companies
in India.
So their paths to those
types of jobs.
But if you wanted to be an
entrepreneur or something,
many of them come from some of
the wide diversity of other
schools in India.
PROFESSOR: And also, on that
question, I think a little bit
about one of the themes from
your paper about different
kinds of modernity.
And it's interesting that we've
talked a little bit
about how, in this country,
engineering is not as high
social prestige as--
even to this day, to some
degree-- law, possibly
medicine are, and that the
kind of modernism of this
country coming out of the
American Revolution had as
much to do with both philosophy,
legal philosophy,
commerce, and that America
was considered a very
industrializing country
in the 19th century.
But it was still
unprofessionalized.
Whereas, as you see through
this period of the 20th
century, where one of the big
issues for a developing
country like India is how modern
is it, how is it going
to catch up with the West?
And through these mechanisms,
the whole idea of nationalism
and building the country
literally has this kind of
engineering connotation.
And I think that generated
that level of prestige.
It's interesting.
I told an anecdote from Bob
Siemens, who is an MIT grad,
who came here about 1940, who
was from an elite family and
did his undergrad at Harvard.
And his parents said,
upper class boys
just don't go to MIT.
And here you have these students
who are upper class
boys from India coming to MIT
during the '30s when most of
the other students would have
been pretty middle class, if
not even still kind
of blue collar.
Did you see anything as
far as differences?
They look very finely dressed
in the photographs you show.
And they would, in addition to
not having not been American,
feel out of place in some
way in that way
during those years.
ROSS BASSETT: So you do have
very many wealthy Indian
families sending kids to MIT.
India has this system of family
businesses, where the
business is passed down from
generation to generation.
And the next generation takes
very active part in managing
the business.
And very often, in the '50s and
'60s, what some of these
business families would do
would be to send the heir
apparent to the business
to MIT to prepare them.
So these people were
billionaires and so on.
And so you have, again, these
people who are really of the
highest social standing in
India coming to MIT and
studying, really, in some ways
quite a bit differently, than
American families.
PROFESSOR: Are there questions,
comments?
AUDIENCE: I'd like to ask a
question about the five IITs
that are founded in India in
the late '50s, early '60s.
The interesting thing was that
each of them was sponsored by
a different country.
And that raises a question
with me about--
we talk about, in this
discussion, MIT being the
focal point for many of the
elite young people that were
coming here.
But given the fact that the
Indian government in 1946 is
proposing that you sample from
around the world, it's curious
that the selections
they made were so
un-American in many ways.
And what was the reasoning?
Was it just that they wanted to
see what was out there and
then to draw the best?
ROSS BASSETT: So it seems like
part of it was maybe a
strategy of--
India had this policy of
non-alignment that they
weren't going to really fly
under the American flag or the
Soviet flag.
They were going to say
we're not allied.
There was this Cold War,
but we're going to
chart our own path.
But part of it was using that
to coerce a variety of
countries to support them.
So when they started this Indian
Institute of Technology
in Kanpur, the United States
engineers at MIT and nine
other schools supported it.
And there was really the idea
of we are going to make this
the preeminent IIT.
It is going to be the best.
And so there was this
competitive aspect.
And I think the Indians
purposely promoted this to get
each of these countries
to the table.
For example, when the Brits
supported their Indian
Institute of Technology, they
had the idea that if we can
train Indian engineers according
to our system, then
maybe when they're out in
companies, they'll buy British
stuff and that will help us.
And so they had that idea.
That was part of why
they were doing it.
And the Soviets, I think, had
the idea that this would be a
model, that this would be a foot
in the door into a way
for them to influence the
development of technology.
So each country, I think,
had that idea.
And India encouraged them
to have that idea.
AUDIENCE: Why not the French?
They're left out.
And yet, the Grands
Ecoles are there.
ROSS BASSETT: So I think if
you had the money and were
willing to do it-- so I think
it must have been that they
weren't willing to put
up the bucks--
AUDIENCE: Post war.
ROSS BASSETT: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
ROSS BASSETT: The British we
were always complaining that
they didn't have the money to
do anything on a scale that
United States did.
And so I could imagine that
the French didn't either.
I mention this in the article.
There was a bit of an irony
that the British were
supporting the an IIT, because
the British themselves
admitted they had no
MIT in Britain.
So they were kind of trying to
do in India what they hadn't
done in England in
a certain sense.